one of my friends got gonorrhea in his
throat what ya got got it in his throat
what was he eating like sucking
bone marrow probably or sucking if
you haven't your throat you got really
convinced people is like yeah part of my
thing is I do a lot of like I I really
do a lot of clicks on a sock because I
suck pussies - bro yeah was that before
or after some guy was knocking your
stalks herp dick I didn't know
you I don't know you were super head on
yeah
by the way effect you got in your throat
I'm already impressed dude I'm not even
a gay man but I always want to give you
a world
yeah listen best friend looked even
worse than that it was like thrush it's
like his tongue was all white and he was
like he was like do you think this is
bad and I was like buddy it's not good
[Music]
you were raised by a single mom I was
and the reason we played Bee Gees is cuz
Jay had a topic that he thought well it
was just I watched the music video for
birdie Higgins Key Largo
hmm bring it up some no and I just saw
the guy and it's just if you asked me to
draw the guys who my mom wanted to and
and the guys that could have my
mom mm-hmm in the 70s / 80s yeah this
guy I'm the guy when did your mom meet
Joe what year does your mom have until
Tricia's off the market for a couple
years 10 so 87 88 87 88 and at the end
of the Reagan administration look at the
sky look he's ripping a butt yeah music
video dude I like that they filmed this
all outside of a nice oyster
restaurant in Florida just like looks
like the lamppost oh yeah absolutely
this guy he just really does that's a
certificate
yeah he looks like particularly even a
guy named Kevin I think that was neon my
mom at one point he looked like my mom's
boyfriend Dennis Yeah right there's such
a nondescript gave his last name did you
have a lot of boyfriend's not a lot of
boyfriends but dated a bunch that's the
same my parents got divorced when I was
1 and my mom like you know like had
boyfriends like she would date a guy for
a few months it wouldn't work out and
like as I got older I realize like any
time my mom dumped somebody and then
like or she got dumped she would get
like upset she would want to like lose
weight I would be like nine years old
eating Lean Cuisines it would just be
Lean Cuisines and like skinny cow ice
cream I was dumped
yeah that's so funny because I didn't
realize that we would switch our
desserts to Weight Watchers yeah I can
fudge circles
yeah if and it would always switch and
it would be and it would be in between
boyfriends when Nick my stepdad was
there Ben and Jerry's every
night baby when I got older as a
teenager if I was coming home like late
from basketball practice and I saw like
two polished off bottles of Sutter home
white zinfandel
I knew was gonna be a problem I knew she
was drinking talking to my aunt Eileen
and it was somebody
see a job my mom went through a super
dark period from when I was like 12
to 16 where it was my friends would go
in our garage we had a recycle bin you
know it's just one Bend that you just
throw all of our plastic in and there'd
be just handles of one seven
five one seven five of southern comfort
yeah and in my friend's blood Tricia's
getting after it was just her and I yeah
so there wasn't like other people's so
they were like dude how many one
seven five sister mom why you look in
the bin going dude swear to god one time
I know one time I was like yeah three
get single mom
no it's mine my dad hey Dad you got up
on my radio show right now you're on the
radio this is a big moment I'll give you
a call I'll give you a call after the
show
[Music]
hey what's my middle name that was real
we should take our second break here and
we'll come back let's put it out to the
caller figure musicians of the time cuz
Chris you said you have a few you think
the few and I have a couple of non
musicians too
yeah I know a couple dude I know an
original Colorado Rockies outfielder
that my mom would talk about how about
you yeah that's our age difference my
mom wanted to bang Chico from sha na na
well we'll figure out more dudes for our
ladies because our dad's ain't here and
they don't know our middle name
bazillion dollars James
wrong by the way what's hilarious is
that's that is my brother's middle name
yeah but that's funny yeah it's just
funny it's just come on James because I
guarantee you if my dad was still alive
and I'd press him for my birthday he
would have that up oh my god and
my birthday's be like June 20th
because it did that my dad did that when
he missed the birthday one year it was
like Joe it was mid-july and I was like
yeah dad I never got a birthday card he
goes alright I said what on your
birthday back on your birthday I was
like on my birthday what day and he was
like June 8th
yeah and I was like the my birthday's
June 24th and he's like I know do you
try to do that but I mean we got your
dad dead to rights on that one
that was class and trip to the toy store
for sure if you're holding this over
your dad let's do it let's take let's
take a break in and why 8 4 4 comedy 9
is the number if you want to call and
tell us who you think what I guess
celebrity musician whatever you think
could bang your mom bang your mom that's
a fun new game on the bond we're hanging
out with Chris de Stefano I mean we're
all in Bee Gees music all day I mean all
three of those first often talked my mom
down for sure let's see if we can get a
trifecta because right now Dante
Bichette goes two ways but it doesn't
reach old ter-bear now she doesn't know
Dante Bichette is ahead long hair thick
but too big you got a size 38 waist
especially you got a thick but right so
- my dad that's my mom's into thick but
flat no Jay and I have no butts we'll
talk about it when we get back
you